so what I'm sure said Thor's hammer is
out here sitting on the stage what's
that about it I I don't know I know
doesn't it earlier I just figured you
knew wouldn't know would know I come out
here and there's Thor's hammer just
sitting here we can't do a show with
that thing sitting there it's stupid
well we've got a gets in the way so I'm
gonna get rid of it right [ __ ] get rid
of it this thing's gotta go
come on man
[Applause]
I'll give it a try
Hey look that was a mistake let's both
try it together all right
together okay let's get in there
I'm gonna do it I guess neither of us is
worthy
[Applause]
sup dudes what's going on oh hey will
arnett what are you what are you doing
here what's going on not much I was just
dropping by and noticed it left this
here that's so funny yeah okay you gotta
turn that stop stop hamming it up how
did you do that how did you do that
what oh dude I'm Thor you're a Thor yeah
come on everybody knows that um I'm Thor
in I'm also Lego Batman
oh hey check this out
are you ready uh-huh Lego Batman Thor
ready yeah
Lego Batman yeah now I'm Thor yeah okay
all right right that explanation went on
way too long
I see why Thor has to overcompensate
he's an easygoing dude yeah tell us what
brings you to comic-con oh dude are you
kidding me
yeah which tale Thor gets and comic god
it's unreal
and you know I'm it's Lego tale Lego
Batman up no one wants to know about
that
yeah anyway listen thanks for keeping
her safe I really gotta run man I got a
date with 20 Harley Quinn's and just
kind of wondering if they can handle it
yeah I can handle it I mean I'm Bojack
horseman for Christ's sake
[Applause]
we'll learn that everybody catch will
arnett